the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so I was hoping that we would have
the next online assignment ready but
Julia 6 the new version is slowing us
down and it'd probably be next time but
my lectures of course are well what I
want to say perhaps is this isn't
intended to be a course in numerical
linear algebra but I thought I couldn't
let the whole whole semester go by
without saying something about how to
compute eigenvalues and singular values
of course you're gonna call AG or SVD or
they equivalent in Python or Julia but
actually the QR factorization that we
spoke about that we spoke off entirely
about last time is the key unexpectedly
unexpectedly you have a matrix a whose
eigen values you want so let's start
with eigen values and it might be a
symmetric matrix i-i'll stay with a
rather than s because it doesn't have to
be but you get special always you get
something special if the matrix is
symmetric ok so this method of computing
eigen values to me at least and I think
too many people came like out of the
blue a while ago but not that long ago
and it worked very well
so
here's the idea it's called the QR
method because you start by factoring
your matrix into QR so here's a that's
can we call it a zero
got some matrix we start with whose
eigenvalues we want and I'll call these
Q 0 and R 0 and you remember what that
means
what that what what's hiding behind
those letters that I've written you have
the columns of a possibly symmetric as I
said but not orthogonal usually so you
find an orthogonal basis you
orthogonalize them you line them up
perpendicular to each other and then
there's a matrix R which is happens to
be upper triangular that connects the
not orthogonal basis with the orthogonal
basis right we we constructed our step
by step and then the idea is write these
in the reverse order and that will be a
1 the next a ok and then do it again and
again and again
and so we're hoping of course that the
eigenvalues didn't change we hoping that
we can forget a 0 start again with a 1
and produce a 2 and continue so we're
hoping two things one will not be hope
we can see that the eigenvalues the
eigenvalues of a 1 and a naught are the
same so we have not changed the
eigenvalues how did we see that if you
had to show that two matrices had the
same eigenvalues would you compute all
the eigenvalues and compare them he'll
certainly not what would you do what's
the best test the usual test the usual
thing you would want to show to they're
similar
that's right so the claim would be that
these two matrices are similar right so
maybe we should show that so we want to
write a 1 in a different way so so the
claim is a 1 is similar to a so we just
have to figure out we have to get a 1
and turn to a 0 so here is a 1 ok so a 1
that's I want to show that that's right
so that's our 0 Q 0 but what is Q 0 from
here Q 0 is what we is our Q 0 is what
do I want I want to put our 0 inverse
over there so so our 0 now for Q 0 I'm
gonna substitute so what is Q 0 its I
multiply both sides of that equation by
our 0 inverse so Q 0 is a 0 is sorry I
said said a and wrote Q a 0 r 0 inverse
right for for q0 i foot in what it
equals and that's done it
that's exactly telling me that a 1 which
is this equals this and that's a
similarity transformation I have not
changed the eigen values so that's ok
the other thing which is the like you
could say the miracle in this thing is
that when I continue to do that for
almost every matrix the matrices begin
to lose stuff off the diagonal
especially below the diagonal by the
ordering that that QR is done so it
you tend to you start with a matrix a
knot you get a matrix a 1 which is like
a little smaller here this part being
nuts especially smaller you do it again
this is even smaller even so I put even
smaller a to even smaller and you keep
going and for most matrices the result
is that I don't know how many steps we
want to think of taking but we get quite
small numbers here especially yeah so
once we get small numbers here little
Epsilon's
that's everybody's shorthand for small
numbers what what would you expect to
see on the diagonal the eigenvalues
because this has the same eigenvalues as
this as this is this and these little
epsilon czar not going to change the
eigenvalues too much so these will be on
the diagonal will be close to the
eigenvalues and actually what happens is
this one comes first
that one is quite accurate first I guess
we should probably do a simple example
to see this happen actually I do an
example in the notes and let me say what
happens so I do a two by two example
which has something like cos theta sine
theta oh I don't know what I've
forgotten what I took and I don't have
that page of notes here somebody here
something here something here
as a as a not and then a one after just
one step has sine cubed theta there and
numbers there that are getting a much
closer to the eigenvalue sorry that this
isn't a full-scale example but the point
of the example is here that this this
off diagonal entry got gets cubed and
the next step will it'll be its ninth
power and then the 27th power so it's
really quickly going to 0 and this
happens so with the cubic convergence is
you know that's a prize in numerical
linear algebra so that's that happened
okay so this arrived on the scene and
quickly blew away all other methods that
were being used to compute eigenvalues
but numerical people being what they are
they wanted to improve it like is there
a way to make it faster and turned out
there is it turned out that the better
way basically the same idea but just you
know you're always looking for a simple
change and it was the idea of
introducing a shift was tried and turned
out to work extremely well so so that's
the improvement so so we take a one know
so how does it how does this shift work
so instead of a not i if i got space
here to do do this instead of a knots i
take a not
- shift so shift is some multiple of the
identity if I just move a matrix by a
multiple of the identity what happens to
its eigenvectors what happens to its
eigenvalues something pretty simple
right because I'm just shifting by si
what happens to its eigenvectors they're
the same this and what happens to the
eigenvalues they change by s this if a
not v equal lambda v then when I
multiply this by V there will be an
extra it'll be lambda minus s because
the identity times the V is just V so so
the it just shifts all the eigenvalues
by s and you try to shift you look for a
shift you this would be great if you
knew lambda n a shift there you would be
looking for 0 then if you shifted them
all by that lambda and it turns out that
would speed things up so so it you work
instead with this matrix as now I'm
again I'm factoring in the Q naught R
naught so that's the work of the method
is in doing gram-schmidt at every step
and then there's a little work in
reversing the order and then I want to
undo the shift so I so you do that
factorization now let's see you may have
to help me to remember what I should do
here so I factor those I reverse those
and then I think I add back the shift
and that's my a 1 so I took a nod I
shifted it I worked with it q are
reversed the order are q added back the
shift to get a matrix and what what am i
of course hoping of
the matrix a 1 and they not I'm hoping
they're still similar I'm hoping so I
did a shift and I undid a shift and but
of course after after doing a QR I have
to check
are these really still similar so let me
just try to check that one again can i
maybe I'll just it's sitting right there
so let me do it again I'm hoping that
I'm hoping that something you know where
did we change oh yeah here we showed
that a1 was similar to a knot and I'm
hoping that's probably still true even
you know the the shift didn't mess that
up let's just try so ain't no a that's R
naught Q naught plus si okay and now
what am I going to do I'm going to what
did i do before I figured out what Q
naught was from this you remember so so
this is our knot now I have to put in Q
naught but Q naught is this thing
inverse times this is this gonna work
I'm I'm like hoping but I don't think I
wanted to get that no it's not Q naught
there what what do I put here and if it
doesn't work we'll leave it as an
exercise okay so yeah cuz I didn't I
didn't sort of start right somehow
okay so but let me just push along to
see what happens so I'm I'm plugging in
for Q naught here I'm plugging in this
matrix so it shouldn't have been
inverted it times are not inverse
who knows it might work who knows so
that's the R naught Q naught right or is
everybody with me sorry about this R
naught inverse and then I have to add s
I so what have I done
I'm just like pushed on believing that
this would work because it it's the
method that that is constantly used now
do I have what do I have there is it
working this is our not a that was of
course a naught R naught a naught R
naught inverse R naught a naught R
naught inverse good minus s what's
what's what have I got there from from
the are not - si R naught what is that
that's - si I look success they are not
cancels they are not inverse so this
that term from from that that that is -
si cancels + s I am finished and lo and
behold we have the same similarity so we
messed around by a multiple of the
identity and it didn't it it actually
makes the thing converge faster if we
choose the shifts well and but basically
the same idea still working ok so that's
that's the QR method well that's the
method we haven't shown and won't show
that except for this half half completed
example we I don't plan to to prove that
the lower triangular part begins to
disappear
gets smaller and smaller and smaller and
then the eigenvalues pop up on the
diagonal it's it's amazing amazing okay
now is there any other improvement we
can make so that's the method and where
is the work and in using that method
because that's what we always focus on
where we spending computer time
well we're spending computer time in
doing the doing the factorization so it
didn't cost anything to shift by the
identity but then we had to factor that
in the Q naught R naught then it didn't
cost much to multiply them in the
opposite order so the work was in Q R so
could we think of anything to improve
that aspect I think could we think of
anything there and then we've got a
really first class method well if the
matrix a I know ik the matrix we started
with had some zeros that that allowed us
to skip steps in doing the QR
factorization so so what am I gonna say
I'm gonna say if a or a not our original
matrix has a bunch of zeros let's say
it's got a whole lot of zeros there
maybe it's well okay I overdid it here I
know the eigenvalues right off but and
so the truth is I can't that saying that
if that it's not going to happen but we
can get zeros with one extra diagonal
that turns out so that here's the main
diagonal everybody
got his eye on the main diagonal and and
and one diagonal if I can get a lot of
zeros but I can't by simple computation
so I'll show you how to get one but I
can't get all loads to be zero because
then I would have the eigenvalues right
there and that well how do I know that I
can't you know in an elimination
ordinary solving ax equal B you really
do get to an upper triangular form right
some operator some some elimination
steps you plug away and your matrix
becomes upper triangular you and you're
golden
but that's too much to expect here in
fact we know we can't do it by simple
steps because if we could do it
if we could get to a you with with a
whole lower triangular part zero we
would have found the eigenvalues and we
know that the eigenvalues solve a system
solve an equation of nth degree and we
know somebody proved centuries a century
or more ago that you can't solve an
instant we equate in by simple little
steps right do you know who that was and
and that you know that fact and and and
what degree does it apply to so that's
an important fact in that you sort of
pick up in in math yeah what are you
fifth degree yeah so five by five and
and up would be this is impossible
impossible impossible there's no formula
to find a simple formula for the for the
lambdas
and similarly for the Cygnus the
singular values so the argument is
definitely a level of difficulty beyond
ax equal B the inverse matrix or
something the pivots all that you can do
exactly if you do exact arithmetic we
cannot find the lambdas exactly but we
can get as close as we like bye-bye
continuing with the QR method so yes in
other words so we can't get we have to
settle for if we want to like at the
beginning improve our matrix before we
start doing that stuff we can get it
with one extra diagonal and do you know
what kind of a matrix
what whose name and I don't know why
yeah say it again
upper hessen burg so upper is just like
upper triangular it's up there but key
person's name is Hessen birth i as i say
i'm that's a Hessen bert matrix so
hesterberg matrix is a matrix with one
triangular plus one more diagonal but
lots of zeros you know order of N
squared something like almost like half
N squared not quite but but close zeros
and you would you could show that those
zeros stay zeros in Q R so that that
really pays off it cuts the cuts the
work down significantly so that's the
full QR method is is step one reduce a
to esenberg form with a zeros and when I
say reduce I mean find a similarity
transformation of course because I'm I
want the eigenvalues
this to end up the same as the his'n I
want to keep the same eigenvalues as I
go and then step two is QR on this
Hessen Burgh matrix with chips so that's
the code that would would be programmed
in item a that's what MATLAB and well
really MATLAB is appealing like other
matrix systems is appealing to la pack
and Linpack you you know the team of
sort of professional numerical analysts
really spend a lot of effort and time
that the book la pack has ten authors
and and you it's you you can download
any any of these codes like the
eigenvalue code so that's what matlab
that's where matlab naturally that's
sort of the Bible for codes in okay yeah
that's I think it's sort of interesting
to know and there's one more good thing
to tell you about this method and it
applies if the matrix is symmetric if
the matrix is symmetric then if we check
all this we could find that the matrices
stayed symmetric if a knot is symmetric
I can check you could easily check
through this and you will discover that
a1 is also symmetric yes you can it
turns out you have a you could rewrite
this with a Q naught and a Q naught
inverse on the other side but that Q
naught inverse is the same as Q naught
transpose because it's an orthogonal
matrix and symmetry would fall out so if
it's symmetric and the N it's in hessin
Burgh form and it stays symmetric at
every step what what can you tell me
about a symmetric esenberg matrix it's
only got yeah you just erase all these
if there are zeros there and if the
matrix is symmetric then we can safely
predict that it will only have one
diagonal above one nonzero diagonal
above the main day in fact it will say
symmetric so now I'll be should write
symmetric Katzenberg's matrix and equals
tri diagonal major yeah three diagonals
so now you really have reduced the time
to do QR so I said you've got a tri
diagonal matrix it'll stay tri diagonal
in all these steps so you're working
with just three n numbers well actually
two n because they're diagonal above and
the diagonal below are the same you're
working with just two n numbers instead
of order N squared and it just goes like
a bomb so that's I for symmetric
matrices and you see that it was all
based there really the heart of the the
heart of the algorithm was QR okay so
that's my took half the class to report
on the favorite way to igwe to find
eigenvalues oh I should say something
about seen the other values so singular
values of course the the singular values
of the matrix are the eigenvalues of a
transpose a
square root square root of those
eigenvalues but you wouldn't do it that
way you would never form a transpose a
well I didn't mention that the other
thing you would never ever ever do so
let me just put it here this is like in
disgrace to solve that equation it's
like okay you know back to first grade
because that's not it's very bad a
determinant come first of all it's
extremely slow extremely slow and
determined it is packing all this
squared pieces of information into end
coefficients and it's hopelessly
ill-conditioned yeah you just you lose
information all the time so it's really
my if this is going on camera it better
go on camera with a with an X because it
don't do it okay yeah so where was I
singular values so a transpose a so
again let's think about what you could
do at the beginning before starting on
qr4 for a transpose a or for the matrix
a what what could you do with orthogonal
matrices so so I guess what what did we
say about symmetric matrices so here's
what I said about symmetric matrices if
you give me a symmetric matrix I can in
just a simple number of simple steps
make it tri diagonal I can't make it
diagonal because then I'd be finding the
eigenvalues and Abel who was the first
person to see that that was impossible
would would forbids it
but so what let me let me write down
what I'm saying here if I have a
symmetric matrix s
I can find a bunch of Q's and Q
transpose and I can put them all
together into one big Q and it's
transpose and what do I know about the
eigenvalues of that matrix let's just Q
is orthogonal always so what can you
tell me about thee this is the same as Q
s Q inverse and therefore the eigen
values are the same it's similar to it
and it becomes tri diagonal after I find
a good q now and therefore same lambdas
which tri diagonal with the same lambdas
now what am I thinking about here I'm
thinking about tell me the corresponding
possibility about singular values I want
to do something to my matrix now I'm I'm
always taking a general matrix a and I'm
looking for its singular values and I'm
looking to simplify it and what am I
allowed to do yeah I guess my question
is similarity transformations left the
eigenvalues alone what can I do that
leaves the singular values alone that's
a fundamental question because it was so
fundamental for eigenvalues by doing
this a matrix and it's inverse I got
something similar and ie checked even in
this class that the eigenvalues same
lambdas
now I want a whole line that ends up
with the same Sigma's and I want you to
tell me what I'm allowed to do to the
matrix without changing the Sigma's
that this is a maybe don't shout it out
immediately let everybody think what am
I allowed to do to a matrix every matrix
has got these singular values and now I
want to make it a better matrix with
more zeros or something if I if I do
that to it
does that change the Sigma's can I do
more than that to it what can I do it
what what group of matrices will have
the same Sigma's as my starting matrix a
so that's a basic basic question about
that about seeing their values and the
SVD so let's let's think of the answer
together okay so it's got it's connected
to the SVD so let me remember the SVD
the SVD I have some orthogonal matrix
then the singular value of the matrix SV
force into their values and then another
orthogonal matrix what could I do to
that equation that would not touch this
guy so I'm asking what invariance
because not touching it means leaving it
on not varying so I'm looking for what
what under what operations are the
singular values invariant when I was
looking at eigen values this was the
operation well it didn't have to be
orthogonal something then it's inverse
but now what is it up there what what
could I do to that matrix a could I
multiply by Q could I when I throw in
there Q it may be not even on the other
end if I if I throw in an orthogonal Q
do I change the singular values or do I
not change the fundamental question the
answer is
no I don't change him I'm allowed to do
that because here's an orthogonal matrix
aq times you if both of those are
orthogonal then the product is right
everybody knows that if a product of two
orthogonal matrix is still orthogonal
better know that I don't know that yeah
so if I have an orthogonal matrix Q and
an orthogonal matrix u I claim that this
is still what sorry and how do I check
it well I use some tests for
orthogonality what would be that what
tests you like to use the inverse is the
same as the transpose do you like that
test so I'll invert it Q u inverse of
course for any matrix that's U inverse Q
inverse but these were separately
orthogonal so that's U transpose Q
transpose and that is the same as Q u
transpose yeah so I used the
orthogonality of U and the orthogonality
of Q to conclude that the inverse is the
transpose so the answer is yes I could
do that now with singular value with
eigenvalues I had to I had to multiply
on the other side by Q inverse or Q
transpose do I have to do that now no
what can I do on the right-hand side I
can multiply by I can leave it alone
then it has the same singular values
because it's the same sigmund there if I
have a orthogonal matrix times the
diagonal times of orthogonal that
diagonal is positive diagonal is going
to be Sigma now so what what can I do on
this side I can multiply by any
oh it's all going on matrix on that side
too so let's call this guy q1 and this
guy q2 I'm still I still have an
orthogonal matrix they're orthogonal
matrix there and the same Sigma popped
in the middle so that's what you're
allowed to do that gives us more freedom
before we got when we had to do
similarity transformations with the same
guy we got it to be tri diagonal but now
we're allowed to do more stuff we're
allowed to use different orthogonal
matrices on the left and right and we
can reduce it even further from tri
diagonal to by diagonal so the so the
first step is getting 0 the the step of
getting zeros reduces it all the way to
that with all the zeros there so it's
it's it's easier then then I work on
this this is the matrix I work on using
a QR type idea some some method like
that so so everybody's seeing that we're
taking where our algorithm is got two
stages one is get a lot of zeros and get
them in places that will stay zero as
part two of the algorithm gets going and
then run part two of the algorithm you'd
stain with its each step is very fast
now because doing a QR factorization is
fast but was there a question yeah yep
so this would I would call this by
diagonal of course and everybody
recognizes that if I have a by diagonal
matrix call it a or a not or whatever
then a transfer what do you think about
a transpose a
what would a transpose a if that was a
what could you tell me about a transpose
a could you multiply matrices like
knowing that where the non zeros are
like in your head and get an idea of
where so if I have a by diagonal matrix
a then sort of implicitly in the SVD I'm
looking at a transpose a and what would
I what would be true about a transpose a
it would be tri diagonal so what I've
done here and what I've done there just
match up you can you can opera if you
don't want to change singular values you
can get all the way to here but then to
find those thing of their values that
would involve a transpose a it would be
symmetric and tri diagonal and then
you'd be in that game right okay so
that's those are the basic facts of Ag
and SVD for matrices of order up to a
thousand say I don't know I'm not enough
of an expert to know where higher
because the in in perfect math it's
gonna take infinitely many steps or Abba
would be very surprised right he would
see you solving for eigenvalues and
instantly equation by a whole lot of
little steps and getting them exactly
right that won't happen but you get them
within epsilon in a number of steps
that's like n cubed so that's pretty
impressive the eigenvalue problem is
being solved in quotes by by an out by a
fast method that that that gets you a
good answer within a tolerance in n cube
steps right so that's great as long as
an isn't too
and then when n is too big which of
course happens you have to think again
so this method will be is a giant
success up to large matrices but then
you have to think again and what is
involved in thinking again well I guess
more thinking so what do you do if the
matrix is bigger
I guess that the next that that Krylov
would say use my method so Krylov would
say especially if your matrix was sparse
can we just remember what Krylov was
Krylov started with a vector b
multiplied it by a multiply that by a
and got up to let's say a to the 999 B
so now he's got us out cried off it's
got a thousand dimensional space he's
got a basis for it thousand vectors that
span a thousand dimensional space and
he'll look at the matrix a only on that
space in other words I won't go into
detail about that he restricts the
matrix to this thousand dimensional
space and he hopes that it's captured we
it we hope that the eigenvector is
almost virtually in that space and
actually I wouldn't wouldn't go up to
let me take a nine out of that hundred
dimensional would probably catch the
eigenvector so if the eigenvector is
virtually in this space then we can look
at a matrix of order a hundred we can
bring a down to just see its action on
that space and any piece of so when so
here's a so I look at vectors V which
are some combination C 1 B
plus C to a B plus C 3 a squared B and C
100 a to the 99 to B plus it an error
and I'm gonna ignore that error because
I've gone I've got up to dimension 100 I
probably say is pretty safe to ignore
that error and then in this space just
looking at the matrix a so wherever a to
the 100th comes in forget it
just think about the matrix a as as
multiplying vectors of this kind in this
space then I have a hundred by hundred
maybe I can value a problem and you know
the big matrix a is reduced to a matrix
of size 100 by do you see sort of what
I'm saying even though the D I'm not
giving the details that that think of a
thing of a matrix a of size a million
and you apply it to Krylov vectors so I
call them little K for a Krylov vector
in this hundred dimensional space so
they have a million minus 100 zero
components you could say this okay this
is in the Krylov space this is a million
K a hundred
oh it's a full there's a it's got a
million components but it's out of just
a hundred dimensional space so when I
multiplied by a it'll have it'll be
mostly in mostly in partly in the Krylov
space k hundreds and a piece out of K
100 and I just ignore that part of the
matrix so I have a hundred by hundred
problem and I solve the find the
eigenvalues and they're pretty good
approximation to the eigenvalues to the
may i hopefully like the lowest hundred
eigenvalues i'd like to know that but i
might not be sure that this idea would
give me the lowest hundred the first
hundred eigenvalues of the of the
million of the matrix of size Amelia I'm
just taking a few minutes here to to
sort of wave hands about what Krylov the
Krylov idea would do and I probably
won't mention Krylov again this semester
so what it can do is look at this
particular type of space because we can
get a basis for it quickly just multiply
again and again by a then we can
orthogonalize that basis
that's gram schmidt in some some form
we're always going back to a grand
Schmitt then I have a hundred by hundred
I have a bate a subspace of size a
hundred I look at the Mait for what the
matrix does in that space and that I
could look for I could find eigenvalues
were restricted to that space they
wouldn't be the perfect eigenvalues but
they would be accurate okay so I didn't
know it would take one class time to
talk about finding eigenvalues and
singular values but we did some
important things we remembered that
similarity is the thing to check thing
to preserve because it doesn't change
the eigen values and then we
for singular values what was the thing
you could multiply left and right by
different orthogonal matrices and
somehow maybe that doesn't have a
established name multiplying left and
right by a q1 and a q 2 transpose yeah
but but the idea is clear and that
doesn't change the singular values we're
ready to move now into real and maybe
our next step which we don't spend a
long time on will be like random
sampling what if your matrix is just way
too big
so that's a new very new idea very
different idea in numerical linear
algebra is just to sample the matrix
could you believe that the answer is
going to come out right
just for a random sample well the odds
are in your favor okay so that's that'll
be Wednesday and then we have lots of
new we'll move onward after that okay
see your Wednesday Thanks